letztes mal in teil eins in der
tiefgarage in cernys hängt der haussegen
zwischen inhaber edgar schnyder und
nachfolger samuel selina schief
[Musik]
selina will das geschäft für 1,1
millionen kaufen sein investor springt
in der nacht vor der
vertragsunterzeichnung mit der bank ab
platzt der traum vom eigenen chef
geschäft die second hand laden kette an
ak in basel mutter und tochter haben
unterschiedliche ansichten wie die vier
boutiquen geführt werden soll
denn ich bin halt nicht den hass der
schale baubetrieb der zinke sync start
nach einem herzinfarkt von hans peter
zinke übernimmt tochter annabelle
zingrich dies in einer wirtschaftlich
schwierigen zeit
zudem muss annabelle den spagat zwischen
familie und familienbetrieb meistern
die restaurants der firma remy marke
luzern patrol peter eltschinger tut sich
schwer die firma den söhnen florian und
bastian zu übergeben
ich brauche nicht dass es ihm so wild
gibt
[Musik]
samuel selina steht ohne geld da der
private investor ist abgesprungen
es fehlen 200000 franken um den verkauf
trotzdem einzuleiten einigen sich alle
parteien darauf dass samuel dem jetzigen
inhaber etwa schnyder demnächst eine
erste anzahlung von 100.000 franken
machen sollen ex anwalt vermerk eine
neue klausel im vertrag bis samuel einen
neuen investor gefunden hat ist edgar
nach wie vor besitzer und haftende
person versicherungsbetrug ist mir ganz
böse geschichte ist versicherungsbetrug
dann bin ich da hängen ich glaub ich
[Musik]
glaube ich muss nicht sagen dass ich
schon so wenn man größere verpflichtung
annika dann und unterscheidet dann ist
rechtlich dienen dürfen es ist traurig
noch mal vor
20 230 gewesen
die frage der übergangszeit bucht sollte
absprachen und und dass wir auf die
richtigen sachen maschinen weniger lose
oder immer von den 100 und die kommen da
raus leute und ich stehe es 1 1
nein machen interessante bin ich der
herr da wo es klafft kraft und geld
bringt einzig die einzige person die ihn
wo sind die ganzen früchte bringt ist es
was ganz locker für uns genau das ist
jetzt diskutieren wir nicht noch mal was
geschafft
das wissen wir alle auf dem tisch
man muss schon ein schritt nach dem
anderen machen und ich werde nach wie
vor dass das mit dem song you've got
will bessere fotos speziell verschafft
kriminell
das areal bietet mini erste waren und
social media newsroom unter erwitter
schaffen damit sie dann explodiert und
so und das muss alles neu lernen und ich
danke schon am nachmittag treffen sich
alle parteien auf der glarner
kantonalbank zur unterzeichnung des
neuen vertrags für edgar schneider und
samuel selina bedeutet diese
unterschrift sicherheit
beide wissen dem anderen ist es ernst
der symbolische wert dieser unterschrift
ist wichtiger als der juristische
somit werden wir vorläufig problem
[Gelächter]
welche märkte da es sagen doppelte
dienste was ich danach haben wir frauen
sind mit dem sektor
samuel hat nun zwei monate zeit einen
neuen investor zu finden
wenn ihm das nicht gelingt erlischt der
unterzeichnete vertrag
im chalet baubetrieb der zehn großmacht
annabelle feierabend
[Musik]
sie muss ihre kinder abholen diese sind
bei den großeltern als chefin eines 14
mann betriebs ist es nicht einfach
familie und geschäft unter einen hut zu
bringen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
annabelle schwester christian ist zu
besuch
sie ist gelernte hochbauzeichner rinn
und wohnt in bern sie hat bewusst darauf
verzichtet in den elterlichen betrieb
einzusteigen
aber sie fühlt sich manchmal
ausgeschlossen person habe studiere das
hat er gut traurig da liegt ja jetzt
ruckzuck öffentlichkeit trainer thomae
mittäter war einfach battery befähigt
sie darum als lokaler ebene tiefer
gestellt beträgt eigentlich geht es mit
uns geschafft sondern ist so mehr
erfahren
das erste vielleicht der gedanke dass
sie sich trafen sich jetzt mit dem vater
verbringen moni und das schlechte feld
dass ich mehr mit dem vertrag seien aber
hauptsächlich mit dass ich da jetzt
geschafft operierte mir dass ich ihnen
auch live zu sehen
das ist leider das verstanden wird was
können wir für ihren papa mit ihrer
philosophie
wo es nach fünf minuten als geschafft
und der stadtteile sagen dass ich mit
papa kunterbunt als leiter nicholas ist
aber gar nicht so spannend dass so viel
los und es geht so viel stil
das ist aber überhaupt nicht
manchmal sind es nicht die zahlen
sondern das zwischenmenschliche das den
unterschied ausmacht
peter eltschinger hat heute geburtstag
er wird 65 jahre alt ab heute erhält er
seine ahv
zum teil mussten sie zu viel
[Musik]
[Applaus]
es sei eine party im kleinen kreis wie
er sagt
ich glaube er innerlich scharfes mitte
muss das wie gesagt wie ich glaube und
los geht s nicht zur muster sonne auf
ich glaube das funktioniert sie schlage
ich das sage ich eben was ich eben seine
erste liebe und das wäre die letzte
ich sage nicht wie die zeitung wenn wir
viel sagt gewehr pensioniert wird
berufsschäfer im heck mit merklich
verzieht wie jeder andere auch zu recht
aber man sieht an der steilen oder
andere ist im froh wenn du die nied ii
kann der nutzer das sind ja gut finde es
wirklich gut finden wenn sie mich das
lied ruckert und zwingend zum gar selber
ist es hilfe her danke mehr also der
staat
[Applaus]
im st galler chance sind zwei monate
vergangen
der 24 jährige samuel selina hat es
tatsächlich geschafft er hat den
privaten umfeld neue investoren gefunden
das geld ist geflossen er ist nun
offiziell der besitzer von schnee der
kasse
edgar schnyder hat sein geld erhalten
sein plan ist es bald nach portugal
auszuwandern und seinem hobby dem reiten
nachzugehen
zuerst muss er aber seine sachen die er
noch im oberen stock hat räumen
[Musik]
die pokale hatte in jungen jahren als
rennfahrer gewonnen 30 jahre lang
standen sie hier im geschäft in dem
geschäft das er nun verkauft hat sein
nachfolger kann mit den trophäen nichts
anfangen
[Musik]
neben nadine süden regeln welche es
wurde ihnen vom multimedia dass man
irgendwelche griechen glauben sie dass
sie die pokal mitnehmen will die sehne
potato und das ist aber weniger als
stolzer ist möchte vielleicht noch unter
der woche wenn man etwas für einen guten
zweck dass die st
[Applaus]
[Musik]
funkel ich
[Applaus]
skeptisch nebenan ist für samuel celina
der mechaniker alltag eingekehrt
er ist froh dass er endlich seine sachen
weg bringt zwei sind ja jetzt muss er
steht aber für konzentrieren und das den
sowie toyota in der zwischenzeit hat
etwa hilfe von seiner tochter und seiner
frau bekommen
[Applaus]
der verkauf des geschäfts ist nicht die
einzige veränderung margrit schnyder hat
nach 28 ehejahren entschieden sich von
edgar scheiden zu lassen
eine trennung ohne streit großteil hat
sich gewaschen besonderes gemacht und
peru
wann ist das für mich wie logan und mini
plan umsetzen
außerdem verstehen ist eigentlich
hüttner gut dann und vielleicht bist
ausgestrahlt wird immer wieder zu
vor wochen noch sechster oder achter 20
ist nicht angeboren braucht man auch
gerne die idee quasi zeit und so darum
leben wir verstehen uns gut dass man
eigentlich humorist sei aber sie
brachten machen es nicht anders
die gebrüder eltschinger kommen mit
ihrem vater peter nicht vom fleck
er kann sich nicht zurücknehmen er kann
nicht loslassen
sie brauchen hilfe von einem
außerfamiliären mediator
ich vergleiche es bisher beinahe
verantwortung übernahm mit rösler mit
laufe seines beispiel print das
christkind muss man leere laufen und das
muss sie schon okay natürlich dadurch
mal als paar meter mehr laufen als jetzt
ich glaube dass das möglich wäre aber
ich nehme mir einfach nur 8 und kreuzer
zum nur mit schulen oder das ist für
mich mit ein punkt für mich selber
richtig ist weiß ich nicht aber zwei
stück beschützen oder evonik will loosli
will ich einfach das nutzt gern macht
was er gemacht hat und immer noch das
erbrecht paraderolle wonach er kommt
weil wir vielleicht nicht weiß was auf
ihn zukommt ich kann meine 27 4 schafft
ihnen wohne ich wohl nie für meine
mitarbeiter mich als präsident das ist
wurscht was das ist kommen ihn als
patron gefährte begrüßt nur bis mitte
die erwartet dass ich das machen und
sagen mir auch eine danke für den
hinweis
etwas immer noch ein dänisches für mich
na gut das muss ja ja aber das bringt
jetzt raus
das muss der tumor so kommuniziert
werden während die operative chef per
motion eine interne kommunikation staub
hin dass die särge wehrt sich eigentlich
korean und bastian also im moment mal
das punkten
und sage er jetzt sagen wohl jetzt
starten die mal hier jetzt denke ich mir
sind es schärfer sich gerade zu einem
und des lehrers diskussion und meine man
muss ins leere lief es für mich bauhof
geschrieben
sie meinen dass im büro merkel wird den
ansprüchen einer einheits letzte wort
das ist es also keine meiner reizwort
aber das letzte wort zeit oder was für
ein schmöker über dem anschlag auf das
marriott etc zu können
das loslassen und ab gehen also das ist
ein punkt ist ein gewisser egoismus erst
der erste schwarze als termin
quasi feiert also dass der pre trade
erste an 86 leute gehabt
[Musik]
isabelle kessler ist vor kurzem mit
ihrer secondhand boutique in ein neues
ladenlokal umgezogen
[Musik]
der neue standort zieht viel mehr
kundschaft an
[Musik]
isabella kann die arbeit kaum allein
ich will sie ja nicht vertragen und es
ist möglich dass sie einfach plötzlich
offen und deutlich ein bisschen schwer
und dann schauen die einfach nicht da
vor allem wenn der computer schon war
denn ist ein nahtloser übergang möglich
während der laden richtig gut läuft ist
im nachfolgeprozess mit ihrer mutter
keine änderung in sicht
isabella resigniert ich weiß einfach mit
es bringt gar nichts
mottoshow immer mal konzertfotos man
sieht an ich gehe morgen vom supersport
ei und den mag ich an ihm und der witz
ist nötigste ausschnitt und fertig und
dann knallt seien oft genug weil sie
betrifft
es ist ich weiß es ist völlig bescheuert
und völlig falsch
irgendwie starken hirtz eigentlich los
ist jetzt so wie das einfach reinmachen
cd eine und wenn ich ganz fest not am
mann hat in rom zimmer geholfen aber 78
isabel us mutter anna maria köster nimmt
die arbeit gerne mit nach hause
hier können sie ungestört kleider
einschreiten
auf drängen ihrer tochter hat sie einen
computerkurs besucht juni bricht die zum
text schreiben selber und so mail
schreiben und und und das habe ich alles
nicht können und hat am laptop stroh und
ab und zu machen auf aber nach wie vor
märz um irgendeines kogler markt aber
nach allem was sie kostet und so es ist
einfach nicht zu
die kleider bewirtschaftung und die
buchhaltung macht sie nach wie vor von
hand ohne computer und auch ohne
taschenrechner
sie rechnet alles im kopf
ihr eigener laden ist für sie mehr als
nur eine arbeitsstelle in pension zu
gehen würde für anna maria fäßler den
ausschluss aus der gesellschaft bedeuten
sie würde sich einsam fühlen
der kontakt mit dem lüd will ich bin
jetzt wo sonst permanent im ausgang ist
und permanent mit trifft dann war ich
automatisch sehr viel 3 1 machen und zu
vielerlei eigentlich war sie nicht so
gut findet älter werden und da einfach
eben das kühle so ist das ist schon so
etwas wie ein sbb oder wo man einfach wo
man hebt im sonnenland ist der winter
eingekehrt
in der schreinerei gibt es wenig zu tun
annabelle zinkl musste 2 schreiner
entlassen und auch ihr schreibtisch
bleibt leer
seit mehreren wochen fühlt sie sich
nicht gut
[Musik]
eine starke stirn und kieferhöhlen
entzündung machen ihr zu schaffen
sie ist beim spezialisten im wartezimmer
[Musik]
endlich habe ich es geschafft dass die
familie und irgendwie ist es definitiv
nehmen
annabelle zink hat eine harte zeit
hinter sich
jetzt ist sie auf dem weg der besserung
[Musik]
barca aller welt ehemann ist ebenfalls
selbstständig er führt mit seinem vater
und seinem bruder eine sanitärfirma die
gegenseitige unterstützung der eheleute
gestaltet sich oft schwierig als sie
jeweils nach hause kam habe ich sie fast
nicht wiedererkannt
das fand ich schon sehr bedenklich
richtiger schlag deutlich wurde
oder hier im spiel funktioniert als
unterstützung des staates gemacht ist
spannend aber es kommt auf den faktor 10
690 mitarbeiter
ich sehe das einfach eigentlich sollte
nicht so harmonisch stoppen
das teilt das ich mein geschlecht größe
nicht möglich
gewisse entscheidungen fällen sich nicht
so leicht wohin soll der weg gehen soll
man loslassen oder doch festhalten
mit dem frühling wagt peter eltschinger
einen neuanfang
er räumt tatsächlich seinen arbeitsplatz
bisher war er mit seinen söhnen im
gleichen büro
[Musik]
ich bin ja alles parat die hinzu und das
welt okay das ist bis zum schönsten
immer sagen ich habe mich an alles was
ich halt welle machen dass vieles noch
oder wieder wie der führer holen und ich
jetzt schön ab und an bastian und tiefen
jetzt aus machen und wie sie einst nicht
genannt genau spielen und es gebe auch
immer schon morgen als er mir ist
wichtig damit nicht
das neue büro ist nur gerade zehn meter
vom alten entfernt
ich werde vielleicht einer meiner
mitarbeiter vermisse nach europa
das ist das gute daran dass man
vielleicht anders kommunizieren also
jedes mal mitarbeiter geht störe dem
schaffen sondern völlig per mail und
langsam denke dass ich weiß du bist ob
[Musik]
diese zehn genügend abstand mit sich
bringen wird sich zeigen
[Musik]
am basler stadtrand in binningen steht
isabelle kessler in ihrer secondhand
boutique das verhältnis mit ihrer mutter
anna maria war angespannt die
unterschiedlichen vorstellungen ob und
wann es eine nachfolge geben soll haben
besonders isabella belastet
wirklich realistisch
sie hilft mir
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die tochter hat ein anderes alltags
tempo als ihre mutter sie arbeiten
unterschiedlich sie haben verschiedene
ziel muss ehrlich sagen ich komme jetzt
wieder beruhigt aber vielleicht muss man
sich attraktive dass man das rennen also
ich habe mir kommt als ich am ja ja aber
ich habe jetzt beruhigt einzelkind und
ist komplett dagegen
vor vier jahren hat isabelle kessler
diese boutique in binningen 11 dieser
laden im unterschied zu den drei anderen
läden läuft nicht er schreibt rote
zahlen
sie hat sich entschieden diese boutique
auf anfang des nächsten jahres zu
schließen
entweder die tochter
anstatt das jetzt wahrscheinlich ein
hoch folgt ist jetzt vielleicht
schlussendlich doch weniger was genau
hat jetzt vor andre ist
isabella hat akzeptiert dass ihre mutter
noch lange nicht ans aufhören denkt aber
mit der schließung dieses ladens sehen
mutter und tochter wieder eine
gemeinsame zukunft auch in graz hat sich
die lage entspannt
annabel ist wieder gesund und sie hat im
letzten jahr einiges dazugelernt
ihr vater hans peter zinke hat sich ganz
zurückgezogen
[Musik]
durisch klärt klar zeigen dass so die
version es geht nimmer vielleicht werde
mit 78 mehr lüthen ob sie aber heute
sind wir alle herrschaft ablieferte
jetzt immer größer warum das muss ich
raus es dort nicht ob es irgendwie
passieren ohne das ist nicht weg so dass
wenn die taste punkten jetzt merkt ja
das ist oder sich wesentlich dass es
chef im bilde was geht
sie hat doch sehr viele gut die leute in
der region zu erhalten
gestreckt gegen bitte sie vor deiner
berühmter darf du kannst eine regel die
ansteckung ist das schönste foto collage
des albert parks ackermann mache das
aber ging es vor allem um krise dagegen
jedes randvoll glaube dass ich war
überrascht dass ich heute mache die
sache mittlerweile machen
[Musik]
annabelle hat ihre position als chefin
gefunden mit zwölf angestellten auf der
lohnliste ist die firma schlank aber
zurzeit auf sicherem kurs hans peter
zinke kann sich sorgen los auf seine
neue rolle einlassen er verbringt mehr
zeit mit seiner frau evelyn
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
dem eigentlich wenn du mich gefragt wenn
die staubzucker das gefühl macht 40
jahre so sehr oft gezögert zu
entschädigen strafen was wird eigentlich
nicht nur der sonne totale rolle der
familie geschafft sondern es ist endlich
fließen und das segel gemacht
wahrscheinlich song zusammen
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
in luzern bei der familie eltschinger
ist das passiert was die söhne florian
und bastian so nicht erwartet hätten ihr
vater peter eltschinger hat ihnen das
feld überlassen und sich ganz
zurückgezogen
ihr seid nur macht mache zahl
grundschule meinte selber dass es
überhaupt so macht und das zeigt für
mich das extrem groß kreutz
ich habe es jetzt die letzten besucher
kommt extrem spielt ja ich bin so fragen
bitte merken sie die sportsitze oder
wieder rennt täter das rx neuen aufgabe
sieht trotz und uns im operativen mit
dem abgang des vaters kommen neue
herausforderungen auf die söhne zu
die frontex druck eingestürzt sind
wirklich auch honig je nachdem was das
gott wo große zeit sind wo sie schnell
mit weltweiten erfolg gemacht hat und
konsequenzen selber noch nicht vor der
termin mit dem rücksprachen haben und
jetzt mit dem man muss machen
peter eltschinger hat eine strategie
entwickelt wie er loslassen kann
er hat sich selber zwangsferien
verordnet und barwerte sommers viel im
ausland
[Musik]
mit das gar nicht machen immer mehr so
alles entscheiden wir haben nicht um
jedes pixel amerika und hat sich am
meisten
100 prozent machen mit 18 zufrieden und
die ich selber laufen will sich mit
phillip island gemacht und ich hatte nur
[Musik]
kürzlich ist florian zum ersten mal
vater geworden
peter eltschinger findet sich nun in
einer neuen rolle wieder derjenigen des
großvaters ich glaube dass es nicht
firma ein eigenes was ich mir wünsche
dass es gut geht und ich wünsche mit
zahlreichen stars es ihnen persönlich
aus mensch mit frau mit der interista
familie gut geht und wenn das
funktioniert denn der zusammenhalt und
den lauf zur vita
[Musik]
lange hat der tüv mechaniker samuel
selina auf diesen moment hingearbeitet
heute ist der tag an dem die neue firmen
tafeln montiert wird
das tüv geschäft heißt nun nicht mehr
schnyder kurse sondern soll in kürze die
tafel wird vor dem geschäft angebracht
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der bauernsohn selina hat sich für 1,1
millionen verschuldet mit gerade mal 24
jahren
[Musik]
so lauten die namen einiger meisterwerk
[Applaus]
ich finde das mit der schulklasse
hotelzimmer land das ist der hsv hat
sich jetzt mit eigenen daten bewegt also
ein stiller
egal ob
teure besuchen
gut
[Musik]
[Applaus]
während sich oben alle über das neue
schild freuen ist etwa alleine im
unteren stock hier hat er sich bei
samuel für die nächsten eineinhalb jahre
eingemietet der 58 jährige möchte ich
ihr spezialanfertigungen machen und hat
nun seine eigenen kunden seine
auswanderungs pläne hatte bisher nicht
umgesetzt
das letzte jahr hat bei ihm spuren
hinterlassen
nach abschluss eines workflows seinem
rumänischen ganz schwierige zeit für
mich hat das wiki davon profitieren
können und so das hat weh tut und
ehemaliger lehrling und europa
und so nicht gesehen was nicht gut
laufen also oder was ich anders wir
machen oder das ist ewig sie aber
inzwischen kann ich mich damit abfinden
und ich sehe auch dass er sehr gut macht
das so gemacht oder und tochter vor
allem und mini ex-frau super haben mit
ihm zusammen also genial ich sehr
relaxed das ja nichts richtig gemacht
aber schlussendlich und ich bin frei für
neue sachen oder eine relativ immun
beschäftige tode
dann geht's ab wenn also die dämonischen
also für mich familie natürlich sehr
brauchen ist eigentlich sehr gut ich
sage auch ne gute dort oben und sondern
sobald sie eigentlich böse aber es ist
so und ich habe mich damit abgefunden
wie es genau weitergeht weiß er noch
nicht portugal sagt er sei immer noch
eine option
die ganzen einweihen damit liegen wir
sind schon froh
wir haben uns nicht
[Musik]
grüße
samuel selena hat seinen traum von der
eigenen tisch wurde verwirklicht
es läuft gut für ihn bis er schuldenfrei
ist wird es noch jahre dauern
jahre in denen er aber genau das machen
kann was seine leidenschaft ausmacht
[Musik]